sentencing in we're hearing joe pike
yeah breaking news judge allison nathan
has sentenced gilay maxwell to 20 years
in prison with five years of supervised
release now gilead maxwell is 60 years
old she's already served
two years almost two years in custody
so she will be
approaching
her 80th birthday when she gets out of
prison now
certainly prosecutors wanted something
far longer between 30 and 55 years and
one victim of delay maxwell told me
going into court she wanted ms maxwell
to die in jail but one thing that was
particularly dramatic that has happened
in the last a half hour is finally we
have heard from ms maxwell who is now of
course a convicted sex trafficker but
through the many years of this uh legal
saga has said almost nothing she did in
court apologize apologize for how
the impact of what has happened on
victims on young women whose lives are
of course
diminished damage destroyed by jeffrey
epstein's abuse she recognizes that she
was close friends with him and really
regrets that but she did not apologize
for her own role in jeffrey
epstein's crimes because of course she
groomed young girls as young as 14 for
him to sexually abuse the reason of
course gillard maxwell hasn't probably
apologized is she still intends to
appeal her sentence she's her conviction
sorry she still
attends to
appeal that conviction on on five
different counts of uh sex trafficking
and that will follow in the coming weeks
and months as for now she has been
sentenced to 20 years in jail
and five years of post-sentence relief
so it is likely she will be in her late
70s almost 80 by the time she leaves
custody we should be hearing from some
of those victims who gave impact
statements in court we expect some of
them to speak outside court certainly
there were tears in the courtroom as
they explained
how that abuse had impacted their lives
one spoke about self-harm alcoholism
the inability to form a relationship the
fact she hadn't had children which she
pointed towards gilead maxwell jeffrey
epstein as
the reason for that and she also said
she'd attempted
suicide uh two times it's been a
emotional dramatic day at the court here
in new york city and it is not over
we'll be hearing from some of those
victims outside court and some lawyers